foreign
yeah
I'm over here and I gotta find more
stuff
I gotta get caught his uh
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
dude
good morning Brook Hollow today is
October 20 1990. this is my TV too loud
I should turn on my TV
more local teenagers have gone missing
they were last seen earlier this week
is that they are all students
Xbox games
that's nice
hope so
information please contact the police
department
I gotta hit them up because my as soon
as it goes live uh if not this weekend
it's next weekend we're gonna go live
pillows but um yeah I gotta I gotta get
one for her cause she's a wrestling for
my damn pillow
yeah
I have to have a travel pillow
you'll see
it's not in this world I was having real
fun taking pictures oh yeah
as soon as I gotta get that link and I
gotta hit up a couple of people
that's like from the house at this size
that's like uh two days travel
ing
is
what the hell
yo he laughed if you know what's gonna
happen
and my stupid ass only played the baby
you know kid is down for all this always
acceptable
okay I'm going to E3 with us next year
I go to that first base point where in
the world hello Max you're here too okay
okay I'm not mad I like it she was
calling out where is here Pete all right
yeah yeah yeah
yeah I identify as Willow yo you stupid
what do we got to do explore our
surroundings
that's right the Lords look at that HDR
at the back
tells you when your TV tells you you got
HDR
oh
and that's not an alarm clock
oh whatever it is maybe I should figure
out where it's all right
yeah we're gonna do some Halo and some
stuff later right I hope I did not
delete it
I don't think I did
I got I'm grabbing all these mushrooms
why am I eating them don't eat them
yeah we gotta put the little things over
yo you hear the situational sounding in
uh the headset
amazing
all brought my PlayStation 5 down here a
common example
you know this kid gonna be right here
with that
an aunt
no addict I do not acknowledge anything
that you're talking about new one for
the Beast
the Analyze This
yeah
he does a whole bunch of stuff oh
[Music]
you wow
um
no what's wrong with you man you're over
here starting Wars we just got here we
know
why you try it
I was just trying to hit you I was just
seeing what I what I'm able to do
okay
all right I don't have anything else
special anymore
oh that's like this is a goofy ball over
there oh another goofy ball what's this
um
this game called win something it looks
like Wind Waker and it's just like this
you Craft boats and stuff
it's in game passes
no you you set it off on the edge now
these answers looking at me weird though
I kind of just kind of was oversized
yeah well he looking at me like the man
hit my cousin
oh damn
we got to
make weapons
we gotta get them we gotta if we gonna
catch one he's right here he's right
here he's right here feed him go
that's what we do take your guts son and
Crossing
everybody
oh
he bit me so anybody got some Bassy
Trace in the rub on us
wow
um you gotta start hold on if you look
at me man you kind of thick back there
man what's up
it's kind of packing and stuff
close now but you're identify it
nosy
no he's right there
get his head now
he's snitching he's snitches he's
snitches
on you I got some common mic fuzz
excuse me oh I can make stuff now hold
on
let's see what we need I'm
[Music]
um you might want to make an ax first
yeah we need weapons we need to ask them
oh they ran up in the spot
yeah we killed a lot of them
curious
how'd you make your ex be what you
needed
[Music]
you should have the materials to craft
it now but you got to get um if you
press start and you go to
um
the Bible God
what I do
nah bro where you make it at
you just make it you can make it
freehand right in the circle the size of
that oh okay
okay
all right
foreign
all right what's it oh I can make a
busting hammer
for some of the better armor and [ __ ]
I'm missing ingredients I'm missing I'm
Missing full Rock
all right I can make it too much a spiky
but I'm missing rocks I gotta go get
some rocks
I need right the sprig right here the
sprinkles yeah
the plant fiber
you um
they look like little baby please
if anything bring the ladybug to the ant
farm and let them jumper don't talk I'm
not I'm not bringing nobody nowhere I'm
nobody to a God I'm new out here
I need two more rocks
oh Springs
okay I know what it Springs is at I need
rocks I found out stuff
I need I need one more rock
all right I got my rocks all right bro
all right so the fiber all you need is
the little um what you call it you can't
find the fiber that's what you're
looking for
what you looking for
spring oh okay okay all right now how do
I equip this is
yeah
okay here comes the Springs right here
Atticus Bridge right here I would like
to be
okay yeah those are those are the
Springs the taller ones my little ones
is
me throw this wood down here man I'm out
here with this wood on it who got that
wood on me homie I don't need that work
I'll drop that wood down man get off me
man an appropriate Wizard's familiar I'm
gonna drop this wood man
property
well I still got into my hand what the
hell you kidding you better ask you made
the accident yeah I got I got my God I'm
sure
okay
oh I got I got a whole stack of 10 man
hold on I need one more public
no
[Music]
where's the water at
here look up look up into the sky look
for grass
okay I see it is wow yeah look at the
all Sky the little tree things to be
having a little water Dew drops
oh what's that on the floor
oh your man here are you next to me
because I'm in my start menu getting
ready to drop it all right
over here all right yes
all right let me go make this ax
I'm just gonna grab these rocks
that's craft
hey crap
yeah I'm hungry and thirsty
oh I can kill ants by myself with this
Hammer hey oh that hammer gets busy yeah
yeah come on
and you could block with
a trigger too
all right I gotta get something to eat
where's uh
where's the mushrooms at or you might
kill one of those black bugs yet yeah we
got a cooking station
a couple stops
um
I need at least a mushroom right now I
had me drink these dirty
all right so why do I feel like over
incumbent
I'm probably am right you probably could
be something right now so press uh
oh yeah honestly kid I would play when
you see the character to me is better
it's better but in the game when it goes
into combat you better go into first
person because it didn't
go back there acting crazy over there
oh so you thirsty I can see it I found I
found I found a new science lab plate
oh for real don't go too far dolo
don't go too far dolo I'm I'm just
looking at this one
I see the thing that I see that's just
water over here yes
see it is that a b
sound like something man I need to turn
this round up
these days
what is this on this on what is this
what is this Salisbury steak oh that's
sap I need to kill one more ant bro
um
there's a whole bunch of water up there
yeah so you gotta yeah you gotta chop
the rice you got the right tree and then
drink it yeah I drink it oh my my
journey I'm super dehydrated
my chicken yeah I hate this one for you
right here all right I see it right here
wait where you at okay okay
drop some uh mushrooms somewhere yeah it
is
mushrooms over here
she tried the other two ladies of the
block s
oh man right over here I fell down I
fell down in the gas
[Music]
these things are no no you press uh
press um
yeah yeah
because you get a lot more out of it
when it's cooked
uh
I think I'm hungry
[Music]
oh
yeah
okay
I'm not used to playing with nobody
oh you'll be doing this solo yeah
we got to do some Morocco oh it's a
daily life is good I'm gonna chop this
down
inventory let me get uh oh right
forehead split forehead split this baby
forehead split forehead split
oh yeah this ax is crazy
the little poker when you get the um
I would highly advise King anytime you
see plant Bible on the floor just pick
it up because
I'm grabbing up everything I'm Walling
right now oh there's more water
drank my water
[Laughter]
how you doing
guys
let me go rough up
they fighting somebody
oh they ate him
oh
ah
where's the dude you dead up there I
thought it was sweet he had three he had
three ghouls on Deck
there's some dudes over here
making it happen making it happen I'm
almost there oh yeah
they still they still over here his bed
is over here
bro you see me turn around
three
all right
I'm gonna try to pick you up
all right
Max
I got you Max don't you worry about it
come on come on we gotta get the fibers
back I gotta go out all right so you
need you need a hammer come on
what you call it no you gotta act
oh she dropped me she dropped me I got
you I got you
mad dudes is coming over here ticks and
everybody
we gotta get out of here
again
I got a mad Shake on me bro
yeah
that's okay where's down here over here
where's that original
yeah
I got a lean the spot where we we
started um analyzing stuff
that's a work bench successful
yeah yeah
it's a lot of stuff
a link to
we gotta we gotta make a lean too we
gotta craft uh uh I gotta I gotta cry
for Pebble wax let me see [ __ ] you do I
have enough
it worked man because I need to put the
armor on yeah
yeah a pebble ax I'm missing rope
anybody got a rope down yourself
by going to go to craft and then go to
the
um left bumper and it should say
material resources the first one excuse
me
for everything
[Music]
all right I made a sleeping spot nice
I gotta make these fibers for these
bandages I made it work better and we're
making one right now but I'm gonna put
it right here and then y'all can move it
wherever I want
I got the workbench
now I'm gonna oh
[Music]
all right how do I switch to that okay
oh um lb lb switches to that
it's okay
all right good all right so we build the
lean too now I can chops oh God
what did you do I threw the piece of
grass and landed on
very slow
listen listen ways to the streets is
gonna be hit
let's sap it all right hold on
it's on the it's on the street baseball
while back on the branches yeah look
it's all the branches
how you get your heart up
okay okay
all right so I need uh fiber that's a
canteen and I need to make uh fiber and
I need sap so I craft that yeah I need
one more sap that I would have had
somewhere
trouble it
the bark on it because I don't know
took this thing like asap bro location
marked okay here we go
if y'all need food
wee boots
oh okay so that brought it up a little
bit yo leave that dude alone my God
yo where's my my my
Whatchamacallit my ax I made an ax
I don't think I threw it
I don't think I threw it unless somebody
yeah
somebody actually sitting right next
yeah
thank you
I'm learning don't mind me no trust me I
used to do that actually throw my ax
about mistake
all right so we we craft basic armor
ourselves right
oh here
don't rush up ants whatever homie it
says eat or die if I die then
we have a workbench
[Music]
yeah
pull over the table
you see 18.
um
I've got to get all right
I need Mike fuzz I'm gonna get that I
know where those mites are
um
[Music]
all right
horrible poncho
I don't I'm missing a lot of stuff and a
lot of it has to do with that mice
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna find those
mites cause yo it's getting late bro
yeah I guess I made that base camera I
need something
hold up
foreign
[Music]
we didn't leave
who's dying
this game it's over by you my daughter
oh
wow
crazy
all right I use it what I do
it's bedtime
someone is trying to get rest
we gotta make our own
yeah but we're gonna wake up like
probably
unlock
the obstructive laser
yeah
which is which which is pretty easy
I can make a spear
I can make uh all I can make is a spare
right now so that's good
I made one
all right so I got one
yeah all right guys
it gives you distance yeah
[Music]
especially like when you we gotta clear
out some water there's some sap down
here I'm just gonna swim over here and
grab that
uh I'm drowning now
oh
man this guy lies a lot there we go I
need something to drink me too I got
something to drink I got a drink
over here let's see what's up
yeah I gotta eat that
if you see any more water oh God man
something up my way bro I just put the
water indicator today
for my little logo
I see you all the way over there
I put it in the air I have a [ __ ]
show it to you yeah
okay how are you saying that like that
how you do is press X and A and you do
little peep it out from a distance
XNA
[Music]
you press X
okay if you see a creature
you press X's you can put your little
boy I got something to eat that I can
drop down yeah where you at here okay
I got some I got some mushrooms
uh it's not my inventory I got you I got
you yeah
[Music]
um yeah
you got it
yeah can't waste food I have enough food
yeah we gotta
sleeping
yo we're sleeping uh head to toe bro
all right
I don't care about squeezing out here
I identify as well
cuddle time with Hoops what's going on
now I gotta put on my Volari pillow
oh man all right all right so it says
wake up
wake up all right
your ax is right here
yeah
oh
oh is that
I just got a bunch of set he accept
skillet
yeah he is this afternoon he just told
myself to him
um
I got it I got it I'm making one I'm
making one right now well I thought
all right I gotta find those those mics
um
we gotta kill those bugs to get so we
can get that red armor yeah
yeah
yeah
all right it's over here where you came
to save me yeah okay yo I have no idea
where the hell I'm going to be honest
with you everything looks the same huh
to myself I see I'm watching y'all
watching
I'm with you
God you could cook mushrooms I know you
can do that I don't even know you could
do that oh that's crazy
I got that I got I got food for us yeah
I got I got wee foods that I killed I
got weeps put them on there all right
yeah put them on the barbie yeah I got
the people beat I put it on the pop and
then cook that up
for today
bring them back
that's how you toss it
I guess I thought I did
yeah I need water too bro life is life
is real look around
drink a fool I ain't doing no work
s
with these slave wages
[Music]
my stomach
crap
all right
I was trying to kill us
all right but how about it
all right now
[Music]
you got it got it yo
they don't care they run down on you
they turn right now
the mice
stupid
no I'm not worried about the bees I'm
killed up too much I need one more bite
for my for my oh my God yeah I'm gonna
get him because I got two they're over
here eating electric and stuff but I
don't have any water
also to switch to your weapons are the
fly kid
um chapped like left foot left bumper
okay between your joints yeah wait let
me follow you
I help you with a pitch when the beef is
off
okay you can go from here to sickle yeah
all right you need ropes all right I got
a bunch of stuff now I need water
I'm listening
now it's daytime I think something's
following us Mateo
oh God
oh God a little bit there's a
spiderweight because if we talk to you
I'm not slurping that dirty water
and like yo you got bad trash water for
you to slurp
you need ropes you need ropes you said
uh
I need I need you currently
yeah
[Music]
I gotta go make some more juice
I don't see no water
if you have a full
if you have a full belly you should be
able to um at least drink a dirty water
okay you know what
then I'm gonna have to drink some dirty
water because on God
all right hold on
I got mad mushrooms
you know what
you didn't mean to you saw me
I watched it we gotta kick him off the
island we gotta kick him off the island
I see that
uh I've been watching them some weird
things
somebody lost their accident King you
guys
I know I threw it I threw it yeah
drink or die so I gotta find a puddle of
dirty water
um I'm about to find out
um
hey fid
um
equip knee pads
[Laughter]
let me cook this stuff over here real
quick then I can put on my wheels suit
attack at it
and cook some weeds too
go ahead
it wasn't even cooked oh I'm messed up
then bro
well
yeah
it was just out here eating raw weed I
put your Weeble back there you go all
right
all right so Pebble spare yeah let me
see let me move it over it's whatever
they need now we can go and grind up a
pants up so we get the ant armor or we
can oh he discovered it yeah somebody
discovered me I made it I made it oh you
made it yeah
and they won't do anything
I don't know if it was out they don't
fall
all right
so all that sap that attic stole from me
he knew exactly what he was stealing it
for he was stealing it for clothes
important bro
so I realized now
I just need this stuff to get ant armor
right now because I mean I'm armored up
for this because this armor is being so
all right
all right so everybody needs to put on
like I should be able to craft some like
at least this grass armor
all right let
me let me get over there and make this
grass um I was looking to add stuff man
I was I was you know I was I was
I was doing Jacob the Jeweler stuff
come here bug oh that bug is gapping boy
that boy
Wings on the street
hammers too
spot you said a camera
yeah which I got a ton of rope like
what we need to do is make a chest in
here and just throw supplies in there
I'm missing rope okay I got that fuzz I
got that spring so I gotta make full
rope let me mix for a rope
good
whatever
all right made that rope I'll get on
this bench
all right got that
Focus
got him
I'm missing rope I gotta get I gotta
make more
because I made that Poncho but that
Poncho took that Poncho took up three
that's what's gonna because we got
enough to make ant like armor and
whatnot we just need this stuff to
connect it
here everybody hungry I gotta put Weevil
on there or we will be
yeah
I'll make a storage basket right quick
yeah we need a storage basket
uh I got it right here next to the tent
that we just put all the materials in
there especially the clovers and all
that stuff
yo shout out to obsidian
making this game
you know some people's crashing projects
turns into the next best thing and
passionate for a reason brother
oh so and how can we restraine if it's
his back are you doing some Gordon
Ramsay
the code just made the trailer of the
kids that got straight
okay you made two storage baskets and
get it
oh that's what's up
any ropes
yeah
I'm gonna rope right now
I'm gonna make five maybe five
let me see
I'm making
no all right let me get over here I'll
make this I'm making that
make oh you got to go to the fish okay
[Music]
why would I make an eye patch
I'm making this poncho
why would I make an eye patch
it's good
I guess it would look good
[Music]
that's cooking
I'll put some weed some water for people
to eat
yeah
I got knee pads
um
the chess piece
yeah I got the armor
all right I got it yeah same here
all right so do my upper body my chest I
got to get that what does the iPad all
right do any if you guys want an
achievement for sitting down but sitting
down you saying yeah
oh no it ain't done bro and Crossing oh
there you go sit in that
sitting there for like five seconds
[Music]
that's what's up all right so
what
happens
I had I was using um
I was using my oh yeah
behind us
foreign
I got the full belly so I can drink this
dirty water
if now if you have like half up or
something after
dirty word is just download
you know what game is like this on a
yeah
a game is like this
fiber bandage out of the Planters so you
can always
yeah
all right hold on hold on let me make a
five Advantage unless it go left wait
wait wait drinking all that nasty water
just kind of screwed up by I have no set
so I need I need hunger
yeah
I like to call myself somebody put a
weevil on there if you got one please
apparently if you get if your Society
gets too big on this game Coggin King
the spiders have like a Wipeout system
where like five or six of them go from
town to town next time it's just
crashing it'll just start breaking stuff
that sucks
we go back again
I think we are good I can't discover
that roast yeah
all right let's go
let's go kill this oh what's this
where'd y'all go
oh yeah
where's where's the higher tier tool oh
where is demon
Where is the
the end I can't remember I'll get you to
it
oh yeah I knew that
oh I'm gonna have one of these out
cooking it I'm just cooking it right now
I got two somebody's really hungry
there's an extra one here don't eat yet
oh they did it they did something oh God
he killed it
uh King before he dies
who's over there I need I need some
water if I can get a drop of water wow
wow
why did you go so far away from us
I was over acting up water it has to be
right there is disgusting
Willow Willow
can I I'm looking up come on give me a
grip of water don't because oh here we
go
sometimes beautiful little trick boxes
too
can you hear me yeah yeah we kill you
all right good all right so you want to
go to the ant farm or you want to uh
unlock the laser beams
okay y'all ready though because you are
you ready ready to deal with those those
bully ants they're like twice the size
of these ones I gotta um aggressive I
got a I gotta get my energy up because
my heart yes I'm ready for the smoke I'm
ready I'm ready I'm over here in the
attic I just need to hold on
King one all right now hold on I gotta
get my heart rate up so I gotta grab
something to make my heart right I think
it's here
all right I need
um sap I don't have sex
Oh either that or I gotta go to bed
drop one on the floor I need more than a
minute
all right that's right it's time to
sleep baby outside all right I got it
funny you need two to make it remember
all right now I gotta use it
put on my inventory
I wish you could I like this I think I
think they did um
the only thing I want is like some
quality updates like if if you taking a
look I would like to be able to like
designate where I can see sap if I bring
up like my goggles if it's in my
eyesight
for the um the machine and we could go
to the machine and be like yo where's
the Snapchat
they do have it it's a little later
attic is down here chilling bugs
wholesale
oh you a kid went out together
hey guys I just wanted to go uh
cut one of the trees out of the way we
got cause we gotta fix one laser which
is over there
I'm not ready I'm ready to do whatever
y'all want to do y'all all right let's
go to the objective let's go let's go
and do the ants all right you got you
got kids talking about I want to do an
objective y'all not doing it and you
know it's funny get close oh let me
repair my damn ax right quick why do you
keep
walking huh
you keep going everywhere there you go
yes stay with us all right where's his
hand here left
smooth Almighty smooth show us
hold on hold on I gotta repair this ax
because it's gonna it only got
uh on this side thank you and go over
here I'm gonna put some Weeble meat on I
didn't drop it did I oh man
all right let me prepare this accent
then we can go prepare thank you now let
me cook some Weeble meat because my
Weeble meat pause is about to be up so
come on the ball before you there you go
whoever wants some weed with me
no yeah I made a bunch of food though
like I made a bunch of food all right
cool let's go all right let's go let's
go let's go
[Laughter]
what is it
it's better let's go all right all right
but all right all right all right all
right cool let's go okay hold on hold up
hold up I'm grabbing two of these I'm
starting to fight with two of these I'm
gonna throw them somewhere oh it's a
video it's a ladybug we should I wish we
could we should walk this ladybug over
there to help because y'all
decongested
all right you guys ready yes I'm ready
bro what what's those three uh
all right they're on I think they're on
the other side here
all right
how do we get what's the easiest way
around yeah what is that sound
nurse
his stomach
follow me or not
I'm trying to get over to do what you
said
yo there's a there's a dead bug over
here it looked like
I see kids he's way over here
I don't know how you get over there oh
he over there okay okay
you see it down there right something
happening down hello yeah
all right
oh God I'm getting nervous I'm not gonna
lie I'm getting nervous like this maybe
we need to reconsider this this is
looking Shady
oh kid did it
no no no no no I put away no I put a
waypoint over there that's all oh
I know who's over here
yeah
yeah
these dudes is over here and these dudes
don't play
I need help
detected
ladybugs
yeah I've never seen that before what is
that go downstairs go down go down now
go down everybody get away it's infected
mate
's wallet
it's affecting mites
oh yeah
yo
Bros
I can't catch my breath
so
[Music]
I got 99 seconds
oh yeah he caught me
so I gotta drink some dirty water I got
I'm going back for my stuff smooth don't
yeah
I'm running
the game
no I'm going for my stuff unless you're
gonna get us up unless you're gonna get
us I'm getting you up I'm getting you up
yo what the hell is this so don't
respawn
if he's gonna do a place where I need a
gas mask
where the hell is the map
what the hell is going on
come on come on
get up get up get up back in the game
I'm not far all right
yeah because you're already dead you're
already dead I'm already dead okay yeah
I ran [ __ ] that dude I've never seen
this
can die but you could if he resets the
backpacks to go over to the where to get
started a game you get all your stuff do
I say game repair
stuff recover backpacks
yeah yeah it's gonna be at the suitcase
okay all right
I need food bro I put food on the barbie
bro what is that
bro
we lost
it's the baseball over here is he should
be closer than we are oh I'm going yeah
that's true I put like that that's the
marker for the base everything
everything looks the same
spider over there
I got I got don't you eat my food
I didn't mean it I didn't need it it was
it was like there was nothing there I
just put something on it
do that why is everything my fault
because you do a lot of stuff
I got 51 seconds and leave it to smooth
to take us to the to the ads and we end
up with some Infected larva
I don't want that beef it's gonna get
dark sooner but but that means
eat our food so don't let them come next
to the group don't know
thank you
I need to eat I need to eat
consume bro
gotta hold it down yeah
my drink cook man I'm cooked I'm cooked
yeah
boy almost died on these streets
oh there's some Infected lovers
I need to make a chess piece man
because I do spit that hot fire that
affected
I've never seen that before I got one
acid going I need acid gland so we got
to kill those dudes to get their acid
gland to get the chest piece
I was in a place where
I need a gas mask
oh okay yeah okay when I started running
from this dude oh they got slippers
oh I got a might hat
so it was towards the dead grass I just
took the wrong turn bro that was a
really wrong turn
yeah you set us up
wow
I gotta drink more dirty water
this dirty water drinking is not nice
no
is cool but it's it's
as far as you know having everybody play
with us you know I'm into that so you
know I want to get I want to get the
screen I think they might they might
open it you don't need that um until
it's not gonna happen today that we get
a chance to play with everybody it
doesn't do that for you until you
find the materials to craft I think I
think they're gonna open this game up to
more people once they uh
once they give you more places to go
like the house opens up
eventually
I'm gonna watch them and call it I'm
gonna go take a nap and run upstairs and
grab my um battery
all right I'm let's all just go to sleep
all right fantastic
I'm trying to use it I'm pressing next
you got the spirit Spike King tablet oh
it's not working I press the X yeah
no no
all right I'm gonna sit in the chair
I'll be right back
let's start making the base
why isn't my um
why can't I use my
use
I did it for the torch
it how do I go into the move the mode
where I can start building a basement
um you uh
you can either do two things you go do
it from a workbench and go to the
[Music]
spider
having a little peep I I don't see the
way of doing it there's no options for
any of the
um hold on hold on
let's see is this something that we have
to it's a step that we have to take
that's why we gotta do the ejector too
you have to be I think you have to do
the address all right well maybe you'll
go
okay Carl you're still here you can come
with us
yeah
yeah we gotta block that
it's not far away either it's not that
far it's this way yeah
I wish somebody had like a
um
ah
by the power of helium all right now I'm
following a year later I see it
relaxation
oh
what oh damn effective Army oh my way
out
here
I'm scared where is he
we far from him
I I love how beard right here somebody's
spear somebody do they spear
I think it was me
I'm not worried about it though you guys
need it I'll grab it and then I'll bring
it back to the basically
so you gotta follow this thing
but we got any torches in here
without torches
I don't have enough material for it I
need to try grass
I think oh I all I gotta do is crap some
more give me one second oh gosh get one
yeah we get one torture that we could be
able to split up
for the bikes I should be able to craft
one right now
it's like impossible to see about that
thing yeah you did it
no bite
well I can definitely hear them yeah
let me get these bite bodies
oh grab these yeah absolutely
here's more of my body's right here
thank you
oh [ __ ] anybody I got a hammer I uh I
made one yes
are you gonna have to chop that down
Tremor detected
something's a foot
I don't see it I'm not scared of that
spider anymore
[Music]
I'm gonna stomp on it
this game is crazy it don't even push
you your stomach
you know I gotta I gotta drink some
water so I gotta drink
muddy crappy water again all right did
we fix it for it or no yeah we fixed it
we fix it all right cool all right go
back
then we gotta press the button on the
day
yo we outside late night bro yeah we did
a little Mission while you was a chair
okay what y'all doing
the world
just move at the torch
ruining too many bars for tomorrow you
know uh you know I gotta have to bring
up that gotta work on gold right
yeah of course I mean
you you do know I'm the one that tweeted
it out before you even saw it right well
obviously you know I would not not see
you you do know you do know you do know
my minions
right so you do know I get any type of
updates but you know who's already hit
me in the background and say don't worry
you still got life don't worry about me
so if it's delay today I'm good
again
right yeah we should be able to sleep I
got some Weevil meat I gotta get over
here put this Weevil weed on Dutch
that we will meet on Deck man cook it up
Chef up some Weevil turnips
you're ridiculous
I'm down with the Weevil meatballs
oh there's some good water over here
oh yeah yeah this water is all over the
place out here
where's water
there's water please
I'm still starving because I drink that
dirty water I'm going to sleep
yeah
oh no this is awesome why are they let
me sleep because they had to sleep too
much you gotta cuddle with the girl
that's me
what is this group cuddling PTSD
oh my God all right I'll go to sleep my
bad I need to drink that water because
if you go to bed when you wake up you're
gonna wake up dead like
oh well then I'm gonna Wake Up Dead oh
my God I ain't had nothing to do like
I'm dead but you'll be like it'll be
very yeah
I gotta eat dandelion meat
sorry
let me see what can I make man
I got that
I got a weevil snout
I got a lot of stuff that I can I can
you know work on like I'm just gonna
drink some water and eat a couple
mushrooms to make up for it
I hear that yeah I hit with the
mushrooms huh
and Empire slippers yeah for some reason
we can't um craft building yet we
probably have to uh all right so y'all
trying to go to the oak tree whoever got
a hammer the eggs
[Music]
wow
okay
[Music]
I'm moving it
oh this is stuff for your house
we started we really Gotta Get It
consistent I don't have water source and
um
yeah
there's a big there's a big juice
cartons uh on the other side of the map
that you can get on the way to the on
the way to the tree yeah let's let's go
but be careful guys like we're about we
have to go to the oak tree and it's it's
it's rough and it's got to move
thank you
all right where's the oak tree lead us
smooth oh well all you gotta do is look
up you see the red lights oh okay let's
let's go towards the oak tree I'm gonna
need something to eat and something to
get so I need stuff to drink so let's
find out our sauce and let's not be
foolish let's share
all right so this food when you see
mushrooms there's food you gotta Breeze
bust that weave up I'm gonna go to the
house and go get the school there's
another weave over here
I got one I need I need the green the
green stuff I think I can eat those raw
with no side effects
all right I need water oh so what's your
real good Jordan oh juice boxes that's
how the juice boxes be having it the big
juice for us well you said juice boxer
that that serves two purposes
for you oh got one got one yes
I won't yeah the blue juice yeah we
gotta fight you gotta I just grabbed it
that was that
these boxes
because every morning
[Music]
drop that
where
I mean there's another Juice Box closer
to the oak tree
what type of crap is this
um
are we still going to the oak tree
yeah just look up we're on a waiter I
know we can go there for multiple
directions oh no no man I got it I gotta
I gotta
hey but I do need to oh let me eat these
mushrooms yeah this is gonna help good
yeah
man because this is disgusting right now
what's happening
hey FID awesome you can't even chop down
you can't even chop down on Big Trees I
mean big mushrooms level we need level
two ax or level two um I know all right
okay
I'll be going to the fall because I see
the trail no no the trees here no yeah
all right I'm gonna get on top of the
branch so I can have it yeah
this tree is real
uh somebody need water it's a good drip
right here that you have to chop down
for you jump ahead
all right
mother stuff over here man all right you
see those acorns yeah we need those we
need corn dogs
yeah those are good for shovels those
are good for um
coming through
I'm gonna bust these eight goals up
[Music]
I'm nervous
yeah be careful there's spiders around
here if you chilling it's daytime so we
good but they be they they mess me
around here
there's uh another Acorn right here
I I wouldn't be able to practice
yeah yeah
you know I'm out here to take your guts
boys
I'm here for gut snatching
oh what you doing
down there oh yeah I'm not going that
way
I saw a spider I don't know about a nest
but all right good I got the shovel
let me know if you see the ground moving
us
but the kid inside
bro
come over here for like apple
hey man
oh there's a dick over here
Stop The Whining dude I do not like that
man my sword is gone you can't give it
back oh oh God all right I got us over
here oh let's cut I'm sitting there
foreign
yo what's behind me
nah [ __ ] nah oh sorry I apologize but
no did you see how big he was not
happening
I'm not dealing with that smoothie
guy come and get me bro this thing came
up out of the freaking I killed you what
killed you my parents oh my God bro I
see it'll be all over by you
I want to be able to get that hold on
hold on hold on I'm gonna try to make it
over to y'all
no let me get your book boy says kiss it
says kissable's backpack no steel oh
spider's over here that might be a
little bit oh she's kidding he sees kids
but guess who's not getting get no me
all right
damn bro
I got the shovel so I have to get my
book bag
[Laughter]
yo yeah I definitely gotta get it if you
go right down that Hill it's a whole
thing of lemonade down there okay
there's two spiders I am okay up here
okay fine yes you lost everything you
lost it all you got to rebuild from life
that's it you gotta rebuild from like
yeah
I'm scared how am I supposed to get
spiders didn't even look like they they
take they take mess why are you messing
with them dude
what's up
yeah bring a ladybug over there man yeah
I'm 56 centimeters for away from my book
bag I'm gonna grab and go
next to you
right next to you I'm looking at you
I'm right here could you come over here
come here
over here please
I'm not going with you with you bugging
you gotta come over here
what look where I am look where I am
it is Hardcore spider got me to wear he
went out he went all the way up there is
there a door inside there can we go
inside there
oh there's quite a house no no excited
where he's at that little house who's
over there I'm going with cars
you go out here get some spiders and
stuff
I don't clean this
thing all right hold on right here right
here let's go to this uh purple uh yeah
I got magic super thirsty
that's what I'm telling you I thought it
was juice it was juice yeah it's bad
juice over here I put a waypoint if
y'all got Thursday
it's soda over there yeah soda juice
water oh my God all right I'm gonna sip
some of that there's also a lot of
spiders over here too oh I'm gonna go
inside the soda can and get this yeah
there's another sip on the floor too
over here
they come and they take all the juice
don't you don't you think about it
there's one over here too
what you think about it let's go to that
purple plane before the next time I
agree we should go to the purple flag
because that's part of the objective
I'm going for it yeah
all right where you at because there's a
giant bird over here next to me
do not go that direction okay do not go
that direction I'm with kids move all
right right here right here let's go get
inside get inside get on top of the oak
branches
right we made it all right hey my game
this is where I paid my base
is living out in front of this in my
game
you called
VR
like stop playing with her play
different games
what was in here
all right
over here just doing everything
yeah he doing stuff okay are you making
yourself too yeah
do you have a torch
Paradise
you know what I'm talking about right
right outside I want to go with people
because by yourself is scary
oh yeah I want to talk to this robot to
get your little side we get cyclists
are you trying to go down there
you know you know you can see obsidian
uh fingerprints
in the game when when you talk to MPCs
or whatever
[Music]
need you cause you got that torch
out your damn mind to think I'm going
down there let's go let's go all right
I'm right behind you kid you know well
you know what I'm talking about right
here God what am I doing y'all talk to
this all together I just need kids in
front because he got the torch
Wait Wait Don't Wait For King wait okay
wait for King
indeed you down
anytime he says that he's up to
something
look at what they asking us to go to
King all right
stay up to something bad at it anytime
Todd tells you to do something it's
because
is
foreign
remember the block King
that is a big ass
in my Adventures manual bigger creatures
I just want to jump one spider
unless we get better weapons
I got the squad
when we Squad right now
leave you on that but
okay
there you go everybody up here there we
go let's go
over here it's real though I'm a picky
eater but still
I feel like we're making a mistake I
don't know why but I feel good
we're about to come across like a giant
spider or something
hold on attic you go without the light
man I can't get
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
all right let's let's get our bearings
I'm going out the other way
you didn't come with us
we just saw that spider I'm going out
the other way
[Applause]
I ain't got no light and I'm out of here
I'm gone
I'm out of here
we got something
yeah so what's this over here come over
here
a little hurt you yeah later
oh we need something to bust that but we
need a little two to bust that oh this
dude is trying to get through the wall
to get to us
who try to get to the wall no
to the left
go go in this area where it's like
you go
you don't care what I think that's right
we're gonna run past them that's the
only way
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait guys because I'm oh man I
need to find out
yo we stuck
yo I want to point out that it was it
was cause ideal to fall into the pit of
death
everything was good it took into the
spot it came out of nowhere and it
it was Oh my he was right at Salvation
he can't kill us all so let's all run a
separate directions that's true I'm so
so somebody gotta take the meat right
this is bad scary though if it's dark
with no light
oh
go go
he's stuck he's stuck
he's stuck
all right
all right
hit him in the butt all right come on
let's go right out let's ride out let's
ride
I'm giving up
dogs I'm gonna need this I ain't giving
up all this material
I don't get real talk if you give it up
that's the spiders don't never be hit
here he really not supposed to be in it
oh it's another one
there's another one another one get on
top of the bridge how about oh
you guys are wrong
there's another one over here
this is
oh my God I heard I heard two of them
there yeah
spiders wow you guys are done I'm done
I'm not doing that no more repair the
game repair the game complete Game
repairs I need somebody to get here it
won't let game repairs I get my foot
back I ain't going back in here it won't
let me it's grayed out
who's the host I'm the host
I got a lot of stuff in there that I
need so I'm going back to my stuff
oh my God
oh
I have my blood pressure
you get over there
yo we was right at the exit I was like
yeah it did this bicycle feet I just
gotta voluntarily pass out
there's too much material in apple bag
for me to try to go back I'm past that I
voluntarily passed out I already passed
out I'm going I'm going to go get it so
respawn or respawn on me now it's
Twitter
like I had to run like five different
ways
save me ladybug yeah big bad ladybug
over here y'all don't want no smoke with
you guys don't kill the ladybug
oh well it'll take a couple minutes but
they can't kill that lady
yeah so far
back
no way no you probably got one of your
older book bags bro I already died
before
I got the one book back that I had and
if I come back now
my book bag my book bags all the way in
that cave bruh God bless okay so can can
I get your book bag for you
oh no all right all right so smooth come
close no I tried it won't let me look at
my stream right now I'm looking at it's
grayed out it will not let me know until
you gotta do it on Pawn death
where the spiders are okay I'm up here
yo the answers kill us
yeah
[Laughter]
we're supposed to be sleeping yeah
this place is safe in the morning we
it's just that when we got out the air I
know what happened
to go we spawn a kid's house going back
to get my stuff I know that spider yeah
that's too much stuff hey Google
there's a ladybug right here
foreign
but I don't care I'm getting my stuff
back
oh leave it for tomorrow man
I got my stuff yo sometimes you gotta
get robbed and you gotta walk it off
got it come back tomorrow with the crew
there's a spider over there
I'm running I see [ __ ] Google's name I
just need somebody to help me get my bag
I want my bag
that's right there's a spider behind you
can't keep running and I need that
chance I think it might have been a
ladybug actually
I made it back with all my stuff
back I got my job I made it back I had
got more stuff in this run than my
actual run on the actual real run yeah I
better decide the base oh God okay oh
God Roar size
oh
and of course I
I made it to the old original base
get ready to oh you all the way over
there
I did what I had to do and when you come
out there
yes when you come out the tunnel you're
able to to go right back to the house
yeah that's the good part about going
through that tunnel because it's a it's
a underground path between the tree and
the original spot
now Lord knows all right where y'all at
come with look I'm in the base
yeah I just made all that stuff for you
because I analyzed the acorns rub
garbage
a gas mask Acorn chest place as soon as
I get my backpack back all right we're
gonna go get yours right back
but kid I got you but we need torches
let me go big we gotta make a torch
because we can't see that kids that we
can't see in it
I I'm too much that was that was that's
going on Tick Tock that's how crazy that
was like
I'm still nervous I'm still shaking a
little bit like yeah
um
it's a horror game
those those science points allow you to
see all all that did that spider we need
the pebble Foundation
all that spider getting stuck was make
me and Cog feel confident and we turned
around doing nothing he's like oh he's
stuck
yeah I can buy the torch upgrade you
want me to buy it
success
inside
matter
can anybody build a torch
let me let me see um let me go over here
all right
oh you got it oh no no that's not an
attic do not go in there with that one
why do not go in there that one is whack
that one will last so quick and we'll be
at a dog I've ran in there with them
I've done this bad times I've been
terrorized by that we need a real torch
trust me trail markers I need driving I
need dry grass yeah so if we go out
front what do you think it's night time
probably should wait do you have dry
grass
we should build a sleep joint in my book
bag if we decide to go and get it all
right then let's just go you you stay
here let's just I have two of these
slime mold torches I have two of them
all right
so it's this way it's this way though
it's this way hold on I kind of want to
drop the stuff I have now because I have
a feeling I'm not I'm not gonna make it
out of this adventure
all right let's go let's go let's go
okay hold on hold on why don't you grab
this other where y'all at uh
when you grab this other toys
all right come on let's go let's go
these toys
I can't put
just don't last long
gotta get kids backpack use something to
drink well if they oh yes they did nice
but the key is if those spiders are
still alive though right here that's
what kid backpacks around this area
street is about spider like
yeah
does anyone have anything to drink
because I die in a in 100 seconds
oh man I think I'll hold on once we get
out of it which states You're Gonna Lose
the light you should have did that
before we waited
oh it's like you ready yeah come here
death to thirst we can't drop it now
is the bodies don't touch them don't
touch them
oh see this thing ran out already and
that's why I hate this way get it oh you
get your backpack yet please serious if
somebody's in my way it's right here
it's right here
all right there you go yes all right you
want to go back that spider's coming oh
man
come on
I told y'all that damn whack light is
whack
with
it's bad for me right now what is that
what is digging under the ground oh yeah
that's the the grubs those got the good
offers
but I got all that all that bag with the
I got an army ant ax
all these spiders is doing is making me
one day
stronger to kill him
you don't put the god in me boy
went to the big bash move in the sky
I'm dead
I see a Giants I see the giant spider oh
I see your body oh damn yeah I see your
backpack did you get your stuff kid
let's go it won't let me do it all right
well you're gonna have to keep getting
it and dying like I did all right smooth
follow me let's go
holy snap
cause I can't see I don't know what's
going on Spider jumped up on it he
jumped up on a gun
oh man that was a fool
s alone
[Laughter]
the tiny
yeah
let me know at some point in time
and then the game would be oh
remember where they at
from an alien world
wait what's that sound
every Earth is trembling
Gotta Give the devs their credit for
years let us see how dope it would be
for honey I shot the kids yeah yeah they
did it it's getting fired
you cover for your backpack or no yeah I
am
looking for the entrance we gotta go the
other way I'm literally I'm next to you
it's over here it's over here over here
I can't go anywhere anyway until y'all
get here because I can't see I have no
torch
a little Blind Faith where'd you go I
want them spiders out there in that
tunnel I'm in the same spot at this time
is it right here
nope I'm right where this purple uh [ __ ]
it up
oh God man I'm good I'm so nervous like
this is ridiculous how nervous I am
right now the thing about how I was
doing this by myself every night
about that leaves us this is the boat
this is yeah
I would I would have definitely
joined in with you
yeah on this madness
I'm inside this is all right you inside
when you get to be up right next to
Addie's backpack I'm not I'm like the
shine of light up in a cave where the
light is coming through from his top
Attica it is safe it's safe where I'm at
I'm deep ahead for this safe where I'm
at
it there you go
I made it over to these dudes an attic
left
what is that up there those are bees
let's see how to get close there you go
here's your backpack yeah this is a
totally different game
all right yours is further all but now
do we have light do we have light not oh
we're gonna have to risk it all for the
biscuit okay I wanna know who told the
devs to make sure spiders are the most
ruthless things that you can run into
has arachnophobia
uh because somebody's terrified of these
things because they live up you know
it's real where they got a bold
all right I'm ready I'm running I'm
running no no no no no no
that's the first one I need the second
one the one that I lost I made it out I
made it out it's a safe attic out there
yes let's go run run right now right now
I'm going I'm going I'm out about I
gotta go I gotta go
thank you because they usually they'd be
ganged up by almost an inches
all right cool I'm good I just need you
and I gotta make this home base because
I didn't do that I would make it by the
water
oh um
wait we gotta sleep that's what we gotta
do yeah where's the little sleeper in
here
the big tree with the um yeah the robot
spot I'm inside I'm inside all right so
let's pick up let's make a joy so we
could sleep and then in the morning he's
gonna be lit see this place is is
dangerous at night but in the morning
you got all your resources two juice
boxes water food you could we could
can't make a base here that's what I
wanted to do
oh my God that was that that it's just
it's just at night it's getting
territory with these spiders
it's lit because they go to sleep and
they don't bother nobody
I don't know how much more this I can
have all right so be outside making it
let's go to sleep hold on should we go
back to dance yeah
make a lean too so we can sleep
I know where everything is at on this
side of the block
outside yeah
hitting your iron moves
you can have this honor yo we told these
dudes when we when we get to we got you
right here right here right there all
right let's go let's all goes 15 000
subscribers we will um giving away
another console right yeah
yeah
we're right next to you all right as
soon as we get up I'm gonna shoot the
supplies
kid like to touch when he sleeps all
right cool so it's a boarding let's go
pick up some armor for real y'all do
what y'all do I'm going to get this this
juice this water and all this good stuff
yeah I'm I'm a cop I need food I know
this this is where this is literally
y'all at where I live
a bad game
oh I need a workbench to craft this
armor but somebody has to craft a word
yeah we gotta we should make all our
stuff here or bring our stuff back all
right so
I do the juice first
who's deathly thirsty mine's at the very
end I'm about to be there all right I
all right I got it you get it you get I
know what other ones you get it
all right all right so I'm gonna go get
the other one is this good water to
drink over here with lily pads and stuff
yo can we die in that water can we swim
you can swim
this one because I need it I'm gonna die
oh damn that was just a little bit
all right anyways we can search for this
boys water drop something spider over
there the spider lurking
what time what time of the morning is it
they usually be sleeping it's a noon
where like definitely like 12. they
usually sleep all day
why are they walking around your
elimination strategy is gonna be much
cause we doing too much
they gotta do AI for four players I've
never seen them do this
told you
look at this door
let's see what's around we doing too
much
yeah I'm not I'm not trying to to hear
that this spider can go somewhere
oh yeah
the attic over here be at aggressors no
I wasn't hitting them or anything
talking bad stroke to the spider he like
what's this tadpoles in the water
I need some water
I will show you do we have the water
that the damn spiders over there I'm at
some water right now and it's time
is doing Patrols
it's broad daylight which I've never
seen before
we could probably kill the little
spiders
we could kill but we can't kill that
wolf spider
I see you
okay this should be a bigger one over
there that we want to stay yo it's a
whole fish down here
it's a whole fish
all right let's jump up oh I can't we
need you
all right get him out a little bit get
him out a little bit
yeah
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
what
it's a big one
oh yeah
oh cause we killed this bear
he can't come to the water he can't
cover the water
yo
it's something in the water yeah
something is it the water
I think
yo get out
oh my God oh my God
[Music]
yo he won't let us go anymore
me too I know where it is but there's
it's between that that can we was at but
it's a spider if he left we could go get
it he won't let us know a whole bunch of
dew drops oh I got drink or a guy oh no
yeah I gotta get close to it yeah I got
a drink of that
eat your Acorn [ __ ]
It's Not Gonna Save Me Brother juice
what's up a little spider that saw you
he was fighting towards you yeah you was
[ __ ] yeah no no you don't see him
because he man listen awesome
my nerves can't handle this this game is
getting nerves huh
where are the Dew drops damn it yeah I
gotta run the drop set Bro I don't
like being here either
out [ __ ] kid I'm looking
and usually around here
22 seconds drink it down oh no just
drink the water
I don't even drink this Acorn [ __ ]
oh I see what oh God yes oh God yes
I made it by the drink box just uh
we're here
damn there's nothing not even not a form
of water all right kid how many seconds
you got for you to enjoy
um
you drink it down yeah all right I'll
look for something you just have to
drink the water smooth
kid
I hate this it's been juice box
oh yeah I got I got how many seconds
you don't have to drink that water man
stop playing and drink that water drink
what water the just the water that's why
the lily pods
for that
all right come kid come to me I see
where you're about a drink box all right
so we're gonna go back to where our base
at is always after it's running around
and I will get food here it's always
after this
area right here it's a dirty one
now go get the dirty water fan I'm
playing around you see this area right
here kid is where the outfits are but
we'll kill him
go get him sped off
oh [ __ ]
dude said I died of dysentery
[Music]
oh here's what
all right let's see here
I got a weevil
you make a little kicking station
we should make a base like right here
yeah right on the Rock right yeah or the
rock I should make a base right what is
cake doing
okay
I had to hide from the spider just in
case the spider went up the face here
yeah let's start building stuff here
this is the spot
cause we got natural resources to
survive
I need drugs
I know where this grass is at
but it's a far track did somebody put
something on here so I can eat oh okay I
got you hold on I got you I got you
guys
this is very much
for two hours see how it goes bro I
please check the whole night
yeah because it's the horror game that
keep you up
is that a fish
yes
[Music]
dry grass hunk because we're gonna need
grass and stuff back here
and I was down in there right so I heard
him because I was over there on the lily
pad over there in the middle right here
and then I hear him
B if you get in a little bit you could
see him just don't Swindle him [ __ ] yeah
let me see I've never seen it you've
never seen them yeah there's something
over there in the water what's that I'm
going over there
you can see him right here
uh
yeah okay make it your yeah
I'll be right here oh I need Cloverleaf
see right here I could get the clothes
right see this is the good part it's bad
Clover leaves here
yeah hold on let me chop them down
we could build a nice base here
yeah
we're probably gonna need actual uh
structures and stuff
yeah we're trying to get build a
workbench too because we can't build uh
the armor that we want we can't build on
the floor all right I built I built the
arm lean two for you
all right we need more food I'm gonna
set it as seat restore point so we die
right here this is a good space to be
honest with you right like yeah
the only thing is at night them spiders
that's it
can we build
stronger equipment
yeah we should be able to now
well all the sap that we find over here
is sad plus there's a sap right behind
us right here all every day look there's
a sap right here with this this all
treated it's where we get into the water
out the water let me grab some here
damn I'm hungry yeah I got a I got a
whole bunch of clover so
and what I like about over here is um
the mushrooms
Clover and to the left you got the drink
box you got the soda kids I see I see a
dandelion but there's a little mini
spider over there oh those is really
good
the dead allowed to let you float fly in
the air floating there yeah I'm scared
to go over there because there's a mini
spider over there I think yeah leave him
alone is it a baby baby one yeah baby
baby one the spider is it a spider
link leave it alone
leave it alone because he gonna snitch
and they relentlessly hunt you until
they get their parents up next
I Spy
[Music]
okay cool
all right
I'm gonna try to make a run for the
draft the grass trucks as we're gonna do
so I can make this no I need grass
planks so I gotta I'm gonna bring them
I'm gonna try to get them
is there any food
I know
yeah you could do that I need to drink
some dirty water again
I'll find dry grass all right uh this
game does not have matchmaking I don't
believe
so what it means super build
to build everything quickly instead of
doing everything one at a time
if you have all the materials you can
super build the whole thing it just
takes like a couple seconds
oh okay thank you
I got the knee pads
um let's just show you what you have
already okay you build a stock can
someone build a storage somebody bring
all this stuff over there
now I'm thirsty yeah Jesus
I gotta leave I got too much
not backtracking stuff
[Music]
all right
hold on bug rub or a holler what's that
smooth part I don't even know what that
is
all right
all right honey food and thirsty yeah
okay where's oh you made the kitty we
need those canteens those are good yeah
you want me to make more
yeah bro yeah oh no we gotta get we got
dick from where that grubs if you can
get like at least like
I'm about to die where's the dirty water
at kick
right there just go right to the pump
yeah I'm about to die I don't have food
or yeah
all right
ready
I hope this doesn't have to keep me safe
I need to drink some water
oh look at the fox probably yeah don't
mess with the Firefly Nature's I'm about
to die
you can't drink the water just drink the
water I don't have nothing to eat is
easy
all right yeah
he's giving you a quick Weeble
bro
I got it I gotta kill I gotta kill um no
canteen is the best thing to have while
you're out in the wild and you see you
don't worry about being thirsty spider
for real
where right there behind you oh yeah oh
yeah I better what about all right you
might want to go to the water let's go
to the water yeah go to the water go to
water basketball be good
see the good things we can run from them
I don't feel the like man he just got us
to abandon everything and just jump in
the water oh you gotta be out gotta be
up
attic if you try to get back up oh okay
all right let me drink oh snap what
grows things under water really and they
give you hydration and food wait what
the Moss the seamos are you serious all
right
go to the floor where you see the
symbols at it was something right here I
just drink some
I see algae
foreign
just gave me mad water back and it was
good water
it's good water this is it
oh there's some bugs
you're right
yup go underneath where oh yeah that was
about good luck yo why don't we make a
Whatchamacallit on the list
make a sleeping tent on the lily pad man
he said I want pizza before we sleep
yeah man
you don't want to sleep
I want to sleep on the lily pad man
[Music]
I don't trust these spiders these that
spider walk the [ __ ]
all right all right it's my God finish
it I ain't got all the materials
and I'm relocating
get off
oh how do I turn this into my my spawn
back point you press X
and set it here
so easy though yeah
jeez man
yeah that's a nice space though yeah we
could build it here he's right we could
build we should build it here
no I'm gonna have to get ready
yeah
but Series S
um as well yeah I play series that's
what this is yeah
over there
oh no I was kissing he just he just
jumped up first yo good looking cake I
never knew about that yeah so I saw him
down and I was just like what's that
movie
yep it gives you good food and hydrates
you quick the hydration was strong too
yeah nobody made these axes that um from
the red ants nobody made the red ant
axes oh yeah clubs yeah I got one
yeah beat these ants up you know if you
that's a two-handed drink and if you
hold it down you do the power move yeah
yeah that's more ants so so build some
stuff
and I'm thirsty again
yeah I gotta go to sleep so we're gonna
go to high school we're safe no I'm not
talking I'm talking about in real life
talk about in the game the game so that
we can get up and get more acorns so we
can make more Acorn clothes
oh attic is building stuff over there
smart man
I'm relocating this [ __ ]
absolutely
get up
yeah the only thing is when you miss
that I wish it was a direct path to the
yeah it's that leash
hold on
what are you doing
he's trying to get up here
what's up make it easier to jump from
yeah we gotta it's hard to make that
jump sometimes
I don't got nothing to dirty water yeah
yeah that yeah go down there and find a
what you call it yeah
oh yeah you should have found that out
algae instead
yeah
it drains your stomach quickly yeah
what's down here
oh I see the allergies
the uh
it's changing the uh the uh
the music was changing that's never a
good sign that's the dark that's when
it's nighttime
wait it didn't I consumed it what is
this
oh but it gives you food cake it doesn't
really give you drink
yeah it gives you food but when you ate
the um
I should have did the dirty water yeah
yeah okay and then you just pick up a
bunch of algae yeah Panic is over there
where the big fish is that that's why
he's saying oh God
there's spiders at the bottom don't go
down there
spiders at the bottom of the water yes
I'm out of this game
slurp nasty water
[Music]
I see what you did
drag the dirty water and then she
checked that
they use good
tell me why
I died
in the water all right so what happened
[Music]
I went so far into the water I need like
a container or something
yeah storage right yeah got my book bag
all right well let me uh uh recycle this
any benefits there's the one already
there
and then you remember boy you I wonder I
wonder if you want to practice them if
you can craft a filter
probably later on
we need to make a bridge this damn thing
I can't get to where y'all at
all right so let's get some rest so we
can get up and yeah I need to get up on
that
oh spider webs do some stuff so we got
to collect spider webs yeah we got to
analyze them too at the machine inside
the building yeah
so a pebble Hammer I could make ax
hammer Acorn shovel I got a crab
I did that
they got arrows
um slime mold torch
oh [ __ ] yeah those are lit that's a
weirdo Shield okay all right
so I got one level two weapon and that's
the red ant club that I'm able to to
rock with
I'm trying to find some uh of those
things
iPads no good no level two stuff here as
far as clothing
I need oh you make a storage box oh I
got those I got those hold on
there go your box
pause
what
the Box
all right I'm putting I'm putting all
the stuff in here because I'm gonna go
explore the bay uh the bottom of the
what's that oh that's for that and
that's for that
you're gonna explore the bottom of the
work of the the lake well I could make
an age one chess plate
I'm putting all my stuff in here oh I
gotta analyze this stuff where to
analyze it oh beside that inside the
tree and the purple I'm going to sleep
I get up in the morning I'll do that in
the morning yeah we do that in the
morning all right
we can't sleep
for
20. you gotta wait a little bit 23
minutes all right everyone put your
stuff in this thing and let's let's go
to like someone else come with me I
don't want to go by myself but what
stuff in there
what you needed now
put the stuff stuff that you're not
willing to lose in those stores yeah I'm
gonna put the dry across yeah that's
true
oh it's got y'all all in it that's why
okay I gotta wait I can't deposit
anything yeah except somebody's using it
get one of the damn Lily Pad bro I'm not
jumping yeah
you got to go from the leaf to the lily
pad you can't get on a little bit it's
just me in there I'm trying to deposit
yeah it won't let me deposit it lets me
deposit certain stuff but not all
because you're in it until you get out
of the menu completely then we could use
it you can't no I'm talking about
um
and it'll say certain stuff that I'm
able to deposit but then it has other
stuff that I'm not able to deposit
but I got these dry grass that I want to
put it in I don't want to lose those all
right I'm
coming right now pause uh deposit that
and I'm depositing that oh it doesn't
let me deposit the stock wow that's
crazy do you have it equipped that's
probably if you have it equipped you
can't you gotta uh yeah you got to
unequip it well I got a lot of stuff
that's unequipped that I uh I can't
deposit but this one it's cool I'm in
here now hold on
I'm exploring I should take the stuff
that needs analyzer that got an
explanation point yeah I was trying to I
was trying to put the um
yeah because we need anything that that
we haven't analyzed is priority to go
back in to the machine yeah all right I
just took it out all right cool yeah I
just wanted to put dry grass in there
because I know a lot of stuff
let me know when y'all ready to sleep
attic where you at what is attic doing
in the morning Jason it's probably cold
outside so wear something more
who called me oh Atticus Peep and stuff
addict peeped attic
I like an assistant
oh there's no more we gotta build a
bigger what should we call it
a bigger one this big fish is like I
can't fit anything yeah we need a
storage chest all right let me see if I
can pick one this big fish is sleepy
yeah
I'm wondering
you sit out one day if I can wake him up
up it doesn't look like oh I could make
a water container that's gonna be bad
important yeah
I feel mad naked without my Ferrari
pillow oh I could make a story no I need
four clover leaves I could get four
cloves right now
that weapon you got
um
um
who has the ant bites the hammer
maybe the the hammer the bus rocks and
stuff
nah that it's like it's a weapon who am
I looking at uh
he's got the club yeah
[Music]
yo want a weapon let me see if I can
make it I don't have any I need uh ant
mandibles the two of them
all right so mushrooms slurry
a thick piece of Blended mushroom bits
oh I hear something crazy
hey you fight
[Music]
he's down there trying to mess with the
fish
[Music]
[Applause]
well me just nobody press the peep
restaurant your hands up yeah I thought
you had binoculars
how you did that
you gotta drink that dirty water drink
some alcohol drink the dirty water yeah
but the thing is is that if I drink the
dirty water it's gonna tell my son my
stomach
oh yeah
watch your face I'm gonna put pants on
there
Mason you slept in that
I got 102 seconds drink or die
tap water
oh my God man I'm now I gotta eat or die
115 seconds
see if I can find something for you
oh go underneath the water look for the
um what you call it the on the dinner
King will talk about the um
you need food to eat I got I got um
mushrooms for you
where you at
I'm under water because I'm coming up
right now you got all algae did you eat
the algae I make it down there as soon
as you said you got food I was like all
right yeah well algae is against the
wall
all of it is against the bottom of the
wall over there but but come in
I'm getting these Clover leaves so we
can make a storage basket yeah
all right we're all right yeah it's
right here okay cool I gotta I gotta I
gotta do a running jump to get over here
yeah I know you got it what you guys
just jump on the leaf
yo what's up
get your face up to the edge
yeah
all right I'm gonna make a storage box
for us I got a bunch of algae right here
for you
he said I got that LG on Deck side
don't don't touch technology got it all
right so I'm about to make storage chest
coming up
I have algae
oh okay all right
oh we're gonna put the storage chest
a whole bunch of algae eat it
[Music]
construct it
you good now
now I got a drink
you didn't drink the water before you
did that I did it I made a storage chest
for y'all all right thank you I know I'm
a picky eater
all the stuff I need in here
with his pebbles in here
I'll put this dry grass in there
tiny peaches ropes in there
acorn
hey Sunset addict trying to risk it all
[Music]
right we gotta sleep yeah oh everybody
ready to sleep yeah I'm ready to show
you yeah I'm ready to get this sleeping
so we can get up and I can get these
eggs on yeah and then we got to go in I
gotta go analyze in the morning
waiting for one more
so I try to fight the spiders at the
bottom of the lake
no you said the spider at the bottom of
the lake yeah man let's go to sleep
I wouldn't saw what kind of smoke I
can't even beat spiders on land
you know he's talking about spiders
you don't want to you don't want to mess
with the spiders at the bottom leg
I don't want to mess with spiders period
look at my backyard it looked beautiful
yeah we're gonna be hungry as hell we're
gonna be hungry thirsty two inches
we gotta make a dew collector we gotta
make a whole bunch of stuff but once we
get to do collector we lit can we
describe this thing
destroy what
I finally killed one
that's how you get that meat those
little yeah
nah not the weevils the little green
jumps
about 52 seconds
you need something to drink what the eat
and drink bro there's water right here
there's water right here it's right here
right here this is by the juice box go
to the juice box get that I'm gonna go
to the kids and point it out to you I
know I'm gonna point it out like
they need to point out bad Interstate
yeah somebody got a hammer
I gotta here let me have a hammer I'll
get these how about juices not a block
all right I'm going oh there's nothing
in here I just it just rolled out all
right let's see if we can find something
over here
usually there's water on top of these
leaves
it went back what if you throw it at the
ground like normal people
all right I need some weevils to kill
someone find me some water and food
while I get these acorns
yeah
we're killing some Weebles here if you
have any um
any algae drink the dirty water and eat
the algae Achilles weevils added kill
these weevils
Coco let's go
you found water
okay you found water
no I don't find any water there's
another one right here they're more um
water than me yeah
but you use foil and water
mushrooms why these mushrooms they got
no mushroom stalks what type of
huh two muscles that's why
what was that that fell over there
I'm really doing too much right now
I found a sad Chomp Clump what is that
yeah
you found a set
yeah
oh it happened it has like thin saps in
it yeah you found the clump
yeah
they sleep in the morning but that's
where they sleep good
I'm gonna go analyze the stuff in the
machine oh yeah do that I need a way
better let me cook some food
laughs
all right start cooking that because I'm
bringing back I need food like that and
water
I got a bunch of acorns holy snap that's
what spider oh
yeah I told you
where the acorns is that well you can
get the [ __ ]
you know what's over there too grubs if
we dig out the grubs you get back good
stuff too but I see a dangerous I got a
shovel oh yeah that little jump that you
see the burying in the ground
dig them out and then rough them up with
your other weapon okay
I'm oh science
I'm really hurting
you know these spiders just walking
around right
yeah Oh Daddy y'all yeah he's walking by
base
is what just walking around like they
were sleeping stuff no no nobody Oh I
thought they were about to get on this
this thing for a second me too I'm like
let me see how far he gonna take this
this is probably not a good idea
let me see if I get some underwater full
uh attic go underwater look for the Army
oh I I have stuff being cooked
oh you're good okay
I see algae yes yo why you somebody came
out the damn base when I was going in
and scared the living crap out of them
you scared the life fighter running
running back towards the base spider saw
me and he put his arms up is there
enough food for two okay yeah go I'll
split it with you there's two of them
here and I couldn't because I gotta not
drown first
go spider
this is one little detail spot it is
acting crazy
oh yeah I'm hungry oh Jesus
ah come on
keep doing my ax my um hammer no I'm
still destroying uh oh how to spot it
over there by the leaf where I need to
be at come on fam I told you
what's up with you
[Music]
how about this dude
I'm just so far he's not came on the
slowly pad thank God
he just while into I ain't doing nothing
told you
oh you already analyzed the um algae
okay that's why you came in here
okay you got a quicker way to get up on
top of the day
bro
it's been a struggle it's a struggle to
get to this base that's the only thing
no all you got to do is jump on the um
the the Whatchamacallit and you jump
straight to it it's fine
though there you go
you said despite is it swimming
okay the spider's swimming in the water
dude
Jesus
where's that food at oh I'm hungry
about me oh finally now let me go make a
ride to analyze the Savage
uh thanks
yo this spider is still running around
town by the Drew fox now
great box
Eagle had to get murdered at some point
he's getting on my nerves
that's not refreshing
beside the building
[Music]
now I'm thirsty already Jesus yeah man
they gotta they got to give us better
juices to Hold Us Down
once we get the Dew collectors you jump
in the water I'm gonna bust you in the
heads yeah
oh
fake me out
he's fake [ __ ]
you know
yeah
I'm going to the analyzer that's that's
too blunt of a weapon to you you need to
use your spare dude I know
see that's when you jump you see what I
jumped from
that's where you jump from
you just jump in
I'm analyzing new stuff y'all
all right I'm going for some more acorns
I just gotta watch out you can drink sap
spider web
sup rope basketball
oh we need them some ropes that's gonna
be for the um
new Collective on Thursday oh drink or
die oh brother
retrieve a super chip for burglar
go
find a hedge lab
yeah that's the next mission that's a
big mission though we we gotta we gotta
build stuff to sustain us before we do
all that
well it's 3 30 guys water
sorry to put an ixnay on the phone
[Music]
this this game is crazy all right kid
where is you said where's the good spot
to jump from because clearly what I'm
doing come here where you at come here
yeah what about doing from where I'm at
see yeah you just jump right here on the
lead all right I'm looking for that
little part oh okay and then you run
over here
it's just the way I was getting to it
yeah no jump on the little league and
then you just right back and then to
leave you do the same exact thing you
just go up to the big league and just
jump back over
[Music]
all right so I found I got a bunch of Yo
and these little acid dudes drop
honeydew
who can drink it
it hydrates you and it gives you some
food so so
we have uh six we have 26 Acorn shells
and 10 Acorn tops
oh you found an analyzer machine to tell
you what stuff at
no I I know that's how many we have I've
been getting acorns
okay we gotta stop building stuff all
right y'all oh [ __ ] there's a spider on
smooth yeah
there's a little one yeah
those buses behind
Brian Dory
he's right here with me what's up catch
it get off Valley
View
for that
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
during the night
[Music]
it's crazy how strong this little spider
is like oh he he even when I was
blocking it hit me with the boys on
you hear me with the boys on
even when I was blocking hit me with the
I'm fixing to die
here I go
help me up even when I was blocking him
with the poison oh
you want to talk about yo they
definitely got what did those spiders
draw
um things web
um
any web
all the time we got a couple I put some
in the Box
yeah I saw it in there
can I have this food
[Music]
yeah I put the food there for whoever
thanks for asking
oh okay I can make silk rope yeah we're
gonna need those eventually
silk ropes we're gonna need for them
because what we need to make that I'm
gonna tell you what's critical right now
we need to make a dew collector so that
in the morning when we wake up there's
four Dew drops ready for us every
morning the keto is what the Dew
collector did we got it before we can
get the do Collective you got to do one
more thing to um
we gotta build that soup thing
so quick
so you can make that nasty so all right
so you this stuff that you can drink you
can drink smoothies right so the algae
smoothie uh with the spring and the
Clover Leaf that gives you a lot of
hills and Hyper stamina
so I'm um I'm crafting one of them
and they have something called boost
juice oh I need three I gotta make a
water container let me get the acorn
show hold on a second
I didn't know super uh certain Waters
nastier than others
all right let me make this um I'm about
to die make a water container
what's a plant a thick paste of blood
what is uh can it rain on this game
yeah it's basically when you wake up
with a boy it doesn't raid but it makes
defense in the Border it's like a water
accumulation
all right let me make this
okay so when we have a canteen next we
need the cant we need a canteen to bring
stuff to it we need to grubhubs to bring
that and we really need to make the Dual
collector but we haven't got the
blueprint yet
[Music]
all right I'm about to die
wait what you dying from a hunger
right there put food on it yeah but let
it cook let it cook though
you let it cook uh I think it said roast
you think yeah yeah
I'm gonna make some what anybody else is
hungry are they good yeah I'm gonna put
this over here called
what what's that
no no we don't need two we don't need
two no no I put it over here
oh you just moved it oh that's what you
did okay okay
a Band-Aid
no I'm gonna try to put more over there
I gotta get used to jumping in my menus
all right
I want to realize that canteen I'll show
you guys go
yeah I'm getting hungry like I'm
starting to get weak I ain't ate nothing
all day
all right are you talking about real
yeah
it grounded or in real life yeah
all right attic I'm down with you let's
get to the safe
how do I share it with you guys
when you save it create save copy
and do you invite a lot of people you
want to have access to this game create
a standard copy or
No No it should be like a sheer shave
copy or something like that share shave
with uh share with friends
yeah
so how do we access it
we get it will become a part of our
saved profile so if you want to play in
this particular world oh that's dope
that I don't even know if she did that
that's fire all right so how do I
thought I would have to wait till I
share it with you guys oh there we go
okay all right
so
share it with me I know I can't get
everything that's already shared with
you Okay cool so when you had to find
King because he's appearing offline
something that's the production
so how would I would go
how would I do it on my own kid
all right you can either if you're doing
a single player it will be it tells you
the name of the world right so I have
one called Planet Xbox the one that
y'all created was
it says owner Lord attic and it's just
yeah
eb64 yeah shared okay I can rename the
save though okay
[Music]
oh you cannot rename a share World well
it is being hosted oh okay
how do I go into that game smooth
okay
[Music]
and then that's what do I join it
[Music]
oh he's the owner Lord addict is the
owner
create stand so I gotta create a
standard
even though he has it okay I mean or no
you shouldn't you shouldn't have to you
could technically create like a copy of
it
Paul one day he ain't on and I'm doing
stuff in that world and then I save it
he'll come back he'll see the stuff yeah
ice all right I had some veterans
in the game and they got some stuff for
me
I'm gonna go in the Stream get something
to eat I am sending you guys to uh looks
like the only people that's on is uh
yeah go over there and uh
uh Jamaican Gamers over there playing
Warzone go over there and uh chill with
him go over there go over there and
chill with it we should go hang out with